we're going to begin with the twin
stories of heartbreak and also courage
this morning from Colorado Springs and
that nightclub shooting we now know the
names of the victims Kelly loving Daniel
Aston Derek rump Ashley Paul and Raymond
Green Vance all died at Club Q Saturday
night when a gunman opened fire there
but on the courage front we are also
hearing the story of a military veteran
who helped bring down the alleged
shooter and save a lot of lives Janet
shamlian is in Colorado Springs Forest
once again this morning Janet good
morning
Tony good morning to you this is a
remarkable story of heroism Richard
Fiero credited with taking the shooter
down he had been at Club cube with his
wife his daughter and his daughter's
boyfriend who did not survive he told us
his story last night how he felt Duty
bound to act almost without thinking
these are good people man these were all
kids
Richard Fiero was at Club Q with his
family when he heard gunfire and his
instincts as a former Army Major kicked
in I just know I got into mode
and I needed to save my family and that
family was at that time everybody in
that room Fiero says he grabbed the
Gunman by his body armor pull the Dude
down
pin him against the side and just start
or I think he went for his pistol
I don't know either way I grabbed the
pistol from him
and then I told the guy moved to AR the
kid in front of me he was at his head I
said move to AR get the AR away from him
and the kid did it and then I started
wailing on this dude and I'm on top of
him I'm a big dude man and this guy was
bigger and I I just kept wailing on him
and I told the kid in front of me kick
him in his head keep kicking him in his
head investigators say fiero's actions
along with that of another customer
Thomas James saved lives but sadly his
daughter's boyfriend Raymond Green Vance
wasn't one of them he was dancing with a
kid
and my daughter got to spend the last
day with him happy
authorities say they're still looking
into a motive our officers and
detectives will continue to be diligent
and thorough in our work to hold the
suspects accountable for these
horrendous Acts
this doorbell video from last year has
serviced showing a man with the same
name and age as the suspect surrendering
to police after reportedly making a bomb
threat this is your boy there appears to
be no record police or family members
tried to trigger Colorado's red flag law
which would have allowed them to seek a
court order to temporarily seize weapons
the man may have had the charges from
that case were dismissed and the case
was sealed now Richard Fiera wants the
focus to stay on the victims and those
who survived I wish I could have done
more okay but those people aren't home
tonight all five of them deserved more
than anyone in this standing here right
now
indeed 13 shooting victims still in the
hospital this morning as is the suspect
authorities say he will face charges
once he's released he will do so from
jail by video conference Tony
Janet Shanley and Forest Janet thank you
very much